what's the worry here nick you've lost
some of your talent as an actor
no
what did he say he says he loves you but
he went in a different direction
i'm done
i'm quitting acting
i'm driving through the hills i'm sorry
one more time
we got another offer it's a million
bucks it's to attend a wealthy
gentleman's birthday party
the guy that owns this house what's his
name cubby hobby mr kate excuse me is
hobby going to want me to uh you know
i'm not sure i understand look it's
hobby i am cubby
nick cage
god this place is stunning what is your
favorite movie that's one of those
questions that's impossible to answer
you can't just limit it to one imagine
me and you
i do
is it too much
is this supposed to be me
it's grotesque
i'll give you twenty thousand four
[Music]
i don't know that was a cliff we could
have died
i'm in position i think that's the actor
nick cage nick h i love you
have you seen proof 2 i'm 44 years old
why would i see croods too i've seen
face-off and con
air you guys won we're with central
intelligence do you know who you're
spending time with one of the most
ruthless men
on the face of this planet i need you to
help the u.s government
[Music]
find a way into that room nick
[Music]
i can see myself doing more of this
stuff i think i might have a real gift
for it good because we got another
mission for you no no no no no no
your friend is working for the u.s
government don't lie to me
are those my golden guns they're my
golden guns i don't want to kill you
you're the last person i want to kill i
love you i love you
okay
[Music]
[Music]